scotland's first minister was in
fighting form brandishing the plan for
an independence referendum next year
pulling no punches as to why now
it really isn't difficult to list the
many ways in which westminster
governance is currently failing scotland
and holding us back
we have a prime minister with no
democratic authority in scotland and no
moral authority anywhere in the uk
nicola sturgeon says she has a mandate
to act and a majority in scottish
parliament to push plans through
but her government is right now under
intense pressure domestically for
failures to hit targets on things like
healthcare and education
the 2014 referendum was described as a
once in a lifetime vote critics of the
new plan say nothing has changed she
hasn't made the case for independence
her
statement today was long on platitude
but short on policies and short on
answers but fundamentally this is not
the right time for another independence
referendum we had an independence
referendum in 2014.
there's also the question of whether a
vote would be legal scotland has to get
consent from westminster something
successive conservative uk governments
have turned down
the uk government today yet again
stressed its position that now was not
the time for a fresh independence
referendum it said scotland like the
rest of the uk had more pressing issues
to deal with such as the rising cost of
living and post coverage recovery but
does that opinion many hundreds of miles
away from here ring true in a place like
this
dundee the highest yes voting city in
scotland in 2014 we didn't know how
things were going to turn out and things
have got progressively worse for people
in scotland and i think if we had full
autonomy we would be able to solve a lot
of the problems that we have i think she
should wait
why
but early i think
for another referendum no i don't think
anybody's prepared for it
i think the support for it
would need at least another couple years
polls show scotland remains as divided
as ever on the independence question
for those more certain in their position
though the campaign starts now
catering over to sky news in scotland